okay does anyone flirt in the mirror
thank you lady at the very top how does
yours start
is it different every time do you have
like an in-road people like to have
freedom enjoying life it starts with
yourself and so I will start myself in
the mirror because I'm always with
myself and it's a great day
what is her name Ashley Ashley
thank you for bestowing that amazing
wisdom on us and I do agree I'm okay
with the world it's the internal stuff
that I'm constantly working on I wasn't
putting this with flirting in the mirror
maybe I should rethink the flirting
because I definitely feel like I'm in a
relationship with myself